chevalier du Moyen-Âge quiui
déambule en armure sur laa
route 138.8.
Il s'agit d'une performancece
de l'artiste français Abrahamm
Poincheval. Dans une chaleurur
suffocante et sous 34 kg dee
métal, ce chevalier a accomplili
dimanche matin sa quête enn
parcourant la dernière étapepe
du périple qui l'a mené dede
Montréal à Québec : une marchehe
de 280 km réalisée en 10 jours..
ABRAHAM POINCHEVAL, artistee
performeur pluridisciplinairee
- Il y a un peu de tensionon
en fait de savoir qu'on arrête,,
qu'on va arriver, que la piècece
va se terminer là. Il y a dee
l'émotion aussi parce que c'estt
pas très loin, c'est pass
non plus tout proche. Mais on aa
l'impression qu'on a fait unun
vrai saut dans le temps.s.
- Et c'était là l'un dess
objectifs du performeurr
pluridisciplinaire : rapprocherr
le pré psent et le pleassé enn
empruntant l'une des pluss
anciennes routes de Québec,,
le Chemin du Roy. C'est aussii
le point de départ drt'unene
réflexion sur la technologieie
et les l déplacements.s.
- C'était de revêtir cettee
carapace technologique ett
de ferrailler avec touss
les véhicules, tous les charss
qu'on voit autour de nous, quiui
sont aussi des sortes d'armuress
du 21e siècle.e.
- L'artiste cinquantenairere
originaire de Marseille n'enen
n'est pas à sa premièrere
prouesse. Il a déjà passésé
plusieurs jours enfermé dansns
une roche ou encore dansns
un ours empaillé. "Le chevalierr
errant, l'homme sans ici" estt
une performance où la douleurr
était bien présente.e.
- Elle a un côté qui estst
beaucoup plus physique qu'ilil
faut réussir à endurer et àà
endosser. Le plus difficile,e,
c'était la très haute chaleurr
qu'on a eu avec des côtess
assez fortes, où là, on a a
l'impression de cuire sousus
l'armure..
- Dans sa démarche, Abrahamm
Poincheval joue beaucoup surur
l'étonnement et l'incrédulitéé
que peuvent susciter les scèness
artistiques qu'il imagine.e.
- C'est ce qui est assez fou jee
trouve, c'est comment on créee
tout à coup cette petite capsule
de magie dans un quotidien..
- C'est au centre d'artt
Le Lieu dans Saint-Roch quee
le chevalier errant s'estt
défait de son armure. Elle estst
désormais l'une des pièces dede
l'exposition retraçant lee
périple d'Abraham Poinchinevale.